Der Krieg in der Ukraine ist noch lange nicht
vorbei.
Aber er ist mit Sicherheit in eine neue Phase
eingetreten.
Nachdem Russland seine Streitkräfte aus der
Nordukraine zurückgezogen hat, konzentriert
es sich nun auf seine neue Offensive im Osten
.
Noch immer werden viele ukrainische Städte
mit Raketen beschossen und viele von euch
werden denken, dass es vielleicht noch zu
früh sei, über den Wiederaufbau des Landes
zu sprechen.
Doch nach drei Monaten Krieg ist klar, dass
sich der Konflikt nicht so entwickelt hat,
wie es der Kreml ursprünglich geplant hatte.
Der russischen Armee ist es nicht gelungen,
die Kontrolle über einen großen Teil der
Ukraine zu übernehmen.
Alles deutet darauf hin, dass zumindest der
Westen und die Landesmitte nicht in Putins
Hände fallen werden.
Aus diesem Grund machen sich einige Leute
bereits Gedanken darüber, was nach dem Krieg
passieren wird, so z.B. Johannes Hahn, seines
Zeichens EU-Kommissar für Haushalt und Verwaltung,.
(Die Ukraine braucht nach der russischen Invasion
einen neuen Marshallplan - EU-Kommission)
Was die Russen gerade in der Ukraine angerichtet
haben und noch immer anrichten ist verheerendste
Zerstörung und Verwüstung Europas seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Deshalb ist es sinnvoll, über eine Art neuen
Marshallplan zu sprechen - eine Investition
in Höhe vieler Milliarden Euro - eine große
Hoffnung für die leidgeplagte Ukraine.
Diese stellt aber auch eine große Chance
für den Westen dar.
Denn den die Wirtschaftsmacht der liberalen
Demokratien in ein Land wie die Ukraine zu
locken, das zweitgrößte auf dem europäischen
Kontinent, würde einen Volltreffer direkt
ins Tor des Kremls darstellen.
Die Ukraine ist mit sehr fruchtbaren Böden
gesegnet und hat mehr als 40 Millionen Einwohner,
eine gut ausgebildete und noch nicht überalterte
Bevölkerung.
Es lohnt sich, der Ukraine dabei zu helfen,
wirtschaftlich und rechtstaatlich voranzukommen
und es vielen privaten Investoren zu ermöglichen,
in der Ukraine zu investieren.
In diesem Video werden wir Euch verraten,
wie viel es kosten würde, die Ukraine wieder
aufzubauen.
Die Frage ist also: Über welche Zahlen reden
wir konkret?
Woher könnte das ganze Geld für den Wiederaufbau
der Ukraine kommen?
Welche Lehren können wir aus dem ehemaligen
Marshallplan ziehen?
Natürlich werden wir heute all diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar wie so oft, indem wir
zuerst einen kurzen Blick in die Geschichte
werfen.
(DER MARSHALL-PLAN)
Jeder denkt, dass die Vereinigten Staaten
den Marshallplan gleich nach dem Ende des
Zweiten Weltkriegs ins Leben gerufen haben.
Das war jedoch nicht der Fall.
Der Krieg in Europa endete im Mai 1945 und
der Marshallplan wurde erst Anfang 1948 von
US-Präsident Harry Truman genehmigt.
Die Wahrheit ist, dass die Alliierten 1945
im Begriff waren, die gleichen Fehler wie
am Ende des Ersten Weltkriegs zu begehen.
Der Vertrag von Versailles hatte Deutschland
so harte Bedingungen auferlegt, dass sie die
junge zarte deutsche Demokratie erstickten
und schließlich zum Aufstieg der Nationalsozialisten
führten.
Aber es gab einen Mann in den Vereinigten
Staaten, der aus der Geschichte gelernt hatte.
Die Rede ist von General George Marshall,
damals Außenminister in der Truman-Regierung.
Marshall war davon überzeugt, dass ein wirtschaftlicher
Aufschwung in Europa für die USA von großem
Vorteil sein würde.
Der Krieg hatte die Wirtschaft und Bevölkerung
der Vereinigten Staaten zu einer außergewöhnlichen
industriellen Anstrengung geführt und er
hatte den Land auch die Vollbeschäftigung
gebracht.
Diese in Friedenszeiten aufrechtzuerhalten,
stellte jedoch eine große Herausforderung
dar.
Die US-Unternehmen mussten hierzu weiter exportieren.
Doch wer sollte ihre Produkte kaufen, wenn
die europäischen Länder nach sechs Jahren
Konflikt völlig zerstört waren?
Auf diese Frage kannte Marshall die perfekte
Antwort: die Subventionierung des Aufschwungs
in Europa.
Das Ziel war, den USA einen großen und stabile
Absatzmarkt für ihre Produkte zu kreieren.
Im Grunde genommen eine merkantilistische
Politik, die darauf abzielte, dass die Unternehmen
nach ihrer Rückkehr von der Kriegswirtschaft
so wenig Arbeiter wie möglich entlassen mussten.
Und einer der wichtigsten Aspekte war: 90%
des Marshallplans waren nicht rückzahlbare
Hilfen.
Das hatte Uncle Sam auch nicht nötig, denn
die in Europa verteilten Dollars würden ja
wieder durch den Kauf seiner Produkte in die
Heimat zurückkehren – und zwar permanent
und mit ordentlicher Rendite.
Im ersten Jahr wurden 60 % des Marshallplans
für Lebensmittel ausgegeben.
Nach und nach wurde mehr in Maschinen, die
Wiederankurbelung der Industrie und den Abschluss
der Wiederaufbauarbeiten investiert.
Letztendlich wurden schätzungsweise 30 % der
Marshallplan-Mittel für Rohstoffe und halbverarbeitete
Waren, weitere 30 % für Lebensmittel und
Düngemittel, 20 % für Maschinen und Fahrzeuge
und 15 % für Treibstoff ausgegeben.
Der Marshallplan diente auch einem politischen
Zweck: er war perfekt in die Truman-Doktrin
eingebettet.
Die Politik von Präsident Truman besagte,
dass die Vereinigten Staaten jedes Land der
Welt wirtschaftlich und militärisch unterstützen
sollten, um die Ausbreitung des Kommunismus
und des sowjetischen Imperiums einzudämmen.
Viele von euch werden jetzt einwenden: Aber
wenn es Subventionen und kostenloses Geld
im Überfluss gibt, besteht doch immer die
Gefahr von Korruption, Misswirtschaft und
Verschwendung.
Nun, in Washington dachte man auch an dieses
Problem und schuf die ECA, eine autonome Agentur,
die den Prozess überwachen sollte, bevor
sie das Geld freigab.
Dabei wusste man, dass eine gesunde Kombination
aus Autonomie, Vertrauen und Kontrolle der
richtige Weg ist.
Keine zentrale Planwirtschaft, aber auch kein
Laisser-faire.
Jedes Land konnte selbst entscheiden, wie
es die Gelder des Marshallplans verwenden
wollte, aber zuerst musste es mit der ECA
drüber sprechen und ein paar Mindestanforderungen
garantieren.
Und es zeigte sich: diese Mischung war genau
die richtige!
In den vier Jahren des Marshallplans erlebte
Europa das höchste Wirtschaftswachstum seiner
Geschichte.
Die Industrieproduktion stieg um 35%.
Die landwirtschaftliche Produktion übertraf
das Vorkriegsniveau bei weitem.
Europa hatte zwei Jahrzehnte nie dagewesenen
Wachstums vor sich und dieses Wachstum kurbelte
die privaten Investitionen an.
Deutschland erlebte sein Wirtschaftswunder
über das wir bereits ein Video gedreht haben
und das ich Euch natürlich hinter i oben
rechts und in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
verlinken werde.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt, solltet
Ihr das unbedingt nachholen, denn dort verraten
wir Euch auch die anderen Schlüsselfaktoren
der Wirtschaftskraft Deutschlands, darunter
auch so einige, die eher weniger bekannt sind
und Euch überraschen werden.
Denn der Marshallplan allein war nicht der
Architekt des Aufschwungs in Europa, aber
er hat zur politischen und wirtschaftlichen
Stabilität des alten Kontinents beigetragen.
In einer so turbulenten Zeit wie dem Kalten
Krieg waren seine Vorteile sicherlich weitaus
größer als seine Kosten.
Und ich weiß, was ihr euch jetzt alle fragt.
Das ist ja alles schön und gut, aber...
Wie viel hat des ganze denn gekostet?
Nun, der Marshallplan kostete 13 Milliarden
Dollar.
Wir sprechen hier von 2% des damaligen US-BIP,
um ganz Europa wieder aufzubauen.
Was meint Ihr?
War das eher viel oder eher wenig?
Denkt mal eine Sekunde darüber nach!
Denn die große Frage ist nun, ob wir heute
bereit wären, eine solche Anstrengung für
ein Land wie die Ukraine auf und zu nehmen.
Natürlich können wir nicht die Tatsache
ignorieren, dass Großbritannien und Frankreich,
welche die meisten Mittel aus dem Marshallplan
erhalten haben, letztendlich sowohl historisch
als auch als Alliierte eine starke Verbindung
zu den Vereinigten Staaten hatten.
Aber bei der Ukraine geht es um ein Land,
das uns bis vor vier Tagen weniger interessiert
hat als das Privatleben von Will Smith vor
der großen Ohrfeige.
Sind wir im Westen also bereit, für den Wiederaufbau
der Ukraine zu zahlen?
Über wie viele Nullen reden wir?
Das werden wir uns gleich ansehen.
(DIE BILANZ DES KRIEGES)
Um es klar zu sagen: Die Ukraine war schon
vor dem Krieg das ärmste Land Europas.
Und warum war sie so arm?
Nun, darüber haben wir natürlich auch ein
Video gedreht, das ich Euch verlinke.
Aber während die Ukraine im Januar 2022 schon
einen Schritt vor dem Abgrund stand, ist sie
jetzt schon einen Schritt weiter, oder vielmehr
einen Stoß: die Russen haben das ganze Land
von der Klippe gestürzt.
Und die Wahrheit ist: Solange der Krieg nicht
vorbei ist, ist es sinnlos, Schadensschätzungen
vorzunehmen, weil die Schäden weiter wachsen
werden.
So sieht sich Moskau durch Fortschritte ihrer
Offensive im Donbas wieder ermuntert, auch
wieder Kiew anzugriefen.
Trotzdem wagen ein Experten zumindest ein
paar Schätzungen bezüglich der bereits eingetretenen
Schäden, so zum Beispiel der Präsident der
Weltbank David Malpass:
(Die Weltbankgruppe hat eine erste Bewertung
der materiellen Schäden vorgenommen.
Sie beziffert die Kosten für Gebäude und
Infrastruktur, also die reinen Kosten, auf
etwa 60 Mrd. USD, wobei die wachsenden wirtschaftlichen
Kosten für die ukrainische Wirtschaft noch
nicht berücksichtigt sind.
Diese Schätzung ist etwas niedriger als die
der Kyiv School of Economics, die von etwa
68 Mrd. USD sprach.
Die Hälfte dieser Zahlen entspricht den Kosten
für die Wiederherstellung der beschädigten
Infrastruktur.
Wir sprechen von 28 Milliarden Dollar an Schäden
an Straßen.
Dazu kommen noch die betroffenen Brücken,
Häfen und Bahnanlagen.
Hinzu kommen 20 Milliarden Dollar Schaden
an Wohngebäuden, die direkt zerstört wurden
und solche, die kurz vor dem Einsturz stehen.
Andere Schäden erreichen nicht so hohe Beträge,
sind aber von großer Bedeutung für die zukünftige
Lebensqualität der Ukrainer.
Der Wiederaufbau von 200 Einrichtungen des
Gesundheitswesens würde weitere 2 Milliarden
Dollar kosten.
Und die Instandsetzung von Schulen und Bildungseinrichtungen
würde ebenfalls ein paar hundert Millionen
Dollar erfordern.
Aber Moment mal, denn wie der Präsident der
Weltbank betonte, ist dies nur der physische
Schaden, den wir beziffern können.
Laut dem ukrainischen Premierminister Denys
Shmyhal werden die tatsächlichen Kosten für
den Wiederaufbau wesentlich höher sein.
(Unsere bisherige Analyse hat gezeigt, dass
sich die direkten und indirekten Schäden
aufgrund des Krieges auf mehr als 560 Milliarden
US-Dollar belaufen.
Und wenn wir diesen Krieg nicht gemeinsam
beenden, werden die Verluste noch dramatisch
ansteigen.)
Diese Zahlen wären etwas höher als die eines
Teams des Londoner Centre for Economic Policy
Research.
Diese nennen eine sehr breite Spanne von 200
bis 500 Mrd.
$.
Aber was bedeuten diesen Beträge eigentlich,
wenn wir sie in globale un dhistorische Relation
setzen?
Nun, der Marshallplan kostete die USA wie
gesagt umgerechnet 2 % ihres BIP und das wären
heute etwa 450 Milliarden Dollar.
Allerdings sind heute im Gegensatz zu 1945
die USA nicht die einzige starke Volkswirtschaft,
die für eine solche Hilfsleistung erbringen
könnte.
Auf alle westlichen Verbündeten verteilt
lägen wir unterhalb eines halben Prozents
ihrer BIPs, also beispielsweise nur eines
Bruchteils der Verteidigungshaushalte.
Dieser Vergleich ist alles andere als weit
hergeholt, denn eine starke, stabile und sichere
demokratische Ukraine wäre einer der wertvollsten
Beiträge zur Sicherheit Europas.
Die Frage lautet also: Ist der Westen wirklich
bereit, diese Rechnung zu bezahlen?
Ist es ihm wirklich so viel wert?
Nun, genau das werden wir jetzt unter die
Lupe nehmen.
(TABULA RASA)
Im Jahr 1991 waren die Ukraine und Polen zwei
sehr ähnliche Länder.
Beide hatten gerade den Kommunismus hinter
sich gelassen, beide hatten etwa 40 Millionen
Einwohner und beide hatten ein ähnliches
Pro-Kopf-BIP.
Von diesem Zeitpunkt an wird der Vergleich
jedoch sehr schwierig.
Seht Euch diese Grafik an.
Ihr seht also!
Der einzige Bereich, in dem die Ukraine erfolgreicher
war als Polen, ist ihr Abschneiden beim Eurovision
Song Contest.
Was also haben die Polen besser gemacht, und
was hat die Ukraine vermasselt?
Der Unterschied besteht darin, dass in Polen
Lech Walesa an die Macht kam, der nicht zögerte,
das kommunistische Regime zu zerschlagen und
sich entschieden für Demokratie und die Liberalisierung
der Wirtschaft einzusetzen.
Auch darüber haben wir ein schönes Video
gedreht und verlinkt, das ihr nicht verpassen
solltet!
Nun, ganz anders lief es im östlichen Nachbarland
ab.
Die ersten politischen Anführer der unabhängigen
Ukraine waren nichts anderes als ehemalige
Apparatschiks der Kommunistischen Partei der
Sowjetunion.
Typische Wendehälse – aber irgendwie dann
doch nicht konsequent genug.
Auf jeden Fall haben seitdem die Unterschiede
zwischen den beiden Ländern immer weiter
Zugenommen – bis zu jenem Extrem, das wir
heute erleben.
1995 hatte Polen bereits den größten Teil
seiner Wirtschaft privatisiert.
Die Ukraine hatte noch nicht einmal den Verkauf
und Kauf von landwirtschaftlichen Flächen
liberalisiert.
Mit anderen Worten: Sie befanden sich im Kindergarten
des Kapitalismus.
Der Aufstieg Polens verlief so rasant, dass
es im Jahr 2004 schließlich bereit war, der
Europäischen Union beizutreten und heute
sind die Polen mindestens dreimal reicher
als die Ukrainer.
Aber die Preisfrage lautet ja: Könnte die
Ukraine ein neues Polen werden?
Und das ist keine Frage an Radio Eriwan!
Denn die Anwort lautet: Ja, ganz real, nicht
nur im Prinzip!
Aber dafür müsste sie sich Europa noch weiter
annähern und sich endgültig vom russischen
und sowjetischen Erbe distanzieren.
Das betrifft nicht nur die Politik und die
Handelsbeziehungen – da ist es ja schon
geschehen – sondern den gesamten Charakter
ihres gesellschaftlich-politische Systems.
Was ich damit meine?
Nun, das ukrainische Arbeitsrecht stammt z.B.
aus den 1970er Jahren, als das Land noch Teil
der Sowjetunion war.
Die beiden größten Banken des Landes befinden
sich in Staatsbesitz.
Die Liberalisierung des Verkaufs und Kaufs
von landwirtschaftlichen Flächen wurde erst
vor zwei Jahren beschlossen und die Korruption
grassierte in allen Bereichen des Staates
auch noch in der Zeit unmittelbar vor dem
Krieg.
Die Frage lautet daher: könnte der Krieg
nicht zu genau jenem Ruck in der Gesellschaft
führen und jene Kräfte mobilisieren, welche
endlich die Errichtung einer wirklich modernen
ukrainischen Gesellschaft ermöglichen?
Denn der Krieg zerstört nicht nur die Infrastruktur
des Landes.
Er reißt auch das ganze Geflecht aus Besitzstandswahrung
und Korruption mit sich.
Es ist klar, dass es noch ein langer Weg ist,
um die Korruption in diesem Land auf ein erträglichen
Maß zu reduzieren, aber es gibt Hoffnung,
denn Selenskyj und seine Verbündeten sind
immerhin die ersten Politiker seit dem Ende
der Sowjetunion, welche schon vor dem Krieg
wegweisende Entscheidungen für die Ukraine
umgesetzt haben, die das Land endlich in eine
bessere Zukunft geführt hätten.
Hierzu zählen massive Investitionen ins Schul-
und Gesundheitswesen und in die Infrastruktur,
welche das erste Mal in der Geschichte der
Ukraine auch zu qualitativ hochwertigen Ergebnissen
geführt haben, anstatt in den Taschen der
Oligarchen zu versickern.
So gute neu gebaute Straßen wie die in den
letzten Jahren entstandenen kannten die Ukrainer
vorher nur aus dem Ausland.
Und ausgerechnet diese wurden nun wieder von
den russischen Panzern verwüstet.
Alles in allem waren die Zukunftsinvestitionen
vor dem Krieg für das Land ein deutliches
Zeichen, dass es Selenskyj ernst damit meint,
die Ukraine aus ihrer Dauermisere herauszuführen.
Nicht umsonst haben wir ihm zur Jahreswende
den VisualPolitik-Award für den Politiker
des Jahres 2021 verliehen.
Eine goldene Wahl, wie sich nun gezeigt, denn
auch in einem anderen Punkt hat er alles richtig
gemacht: Er hat alles auf den Beitritt zur
Europäischen Union gesetzt.
Um es klar zu sagen: Wenn die Ukraine es schafft,
alle Maßnahmen umzusetzen, welche die Voraussetzungen
für den Beitritt zu Europa schaffen, bedeutet
dies, dass sie sich in die richtige Richtung
bewegt.
Aber nicht nur das!
Diese würden auch eine sehr wichtige Geldquelle
für den Wiederaufbau darstellen.
Hierzu hilft ein Blick nach Polen: In den
ersten 15 Jahren seiner Mitgliedschaft in
der Europäischen Union hat Polen nicht weniger
als 160 Milliarden Euro an EU-Geldern erhalten.
Natürlich ist die EU kein Garant dafür,
dass nicht viel Geld in korrupten Kanälen
versickert – siehe unsere Videos zu diesem
Thema.
Trotzdem wäre es sicherlich besser, die Finanzierung
des Wiederaufbaus wenigstens unter gewisse
internationalen Kontrollmechanismen zu stelen
und die Ukraine dadurch zu weiteren Reformen
ihrer staatlichen Strukturen und zur Integration
in europäische Standards zu zwingen.
Schließlich wies auch beim Marschallplan
eine gesunde Kombination aus Autonomie, Vertrauen
und Kontrolle den Weg zum Erfolg.
Gut, aber wie wir gesehen haben, braucht die
Ukraine ja viel mehr als das, worhin haben
wir über 500 Milliarden Dollar gesprochen.
Woher könnte also der Rest kommen?
Nun, genau das werden wir uns jetzt ansehen.
(DIE GESCHICHTE WIRD VON DEN SIEGERN GESCHRIEBEN)
Die Ukraine hat bereits einen Fonds für den
Wiederaufbau des Landes eingerichtet.
Er ist in vier verschiedene Fonds unterteilt.
Einer ist auf die Reparatur der zerstörten
Infrastruktur ausgerichtet, ein anderer auf
die Erfüllung der finanziellen Verpflichtungen
des Landes und die Begleichung seiner Schulden,
der dritte auf die Unterstützung von kleinen
und mittelständischen Unternehmen, um die
Normalität im privaten Sektor wiederherzustellen,
und der vierte dient der Modernisierung des
Landes.
Die Ukraine hat einen sehr interessanten IT-Sektor
mit gut ausgebildeten Fachkräften und schon
vor dem Krieg hat Selenskyj auf diesen gesetzt.
(Wir wollen die Ukraine in ein Land der Start-ups
verwandeln.
Wir gehen davon aus, dass der Technologieanteil
am BIP bis 2025 von 4 auf 10 % und damit auf
16,5 Milliarden US-Dollar ansteigen wird,
was uns zum größten Tech-Hub Europas machen
wird.
- Volodymir Zelensky, Präsident der Ukraine)
Natürlich stammt diese Aussage aus der Zeit
vor dem Krieg.
Aber die Absicht Selenskyjs ist klar und die
Ukraine hat das Zeug dazu - und die Talene
–, um ihren IT-Sektor schnell wieder aufzubauen.
Und seien wir mal ehrlich: Die ukrainischen
Gehälter könnten für westliche Unternehmen
sehr attraktiv sein.
Mit anderen Worten: billige und gute Arbeitskräfte
für europäische und US-amerikanische Technologiefirmen,
die unter eklatantem Arbeitskräftemangel
leiden.
Gut, aber die Ukraine wird für ihren Aufbau
noch noch mehr Geld brauchen, viel viel mehr.
Und woher könnte dieses noch kommen?
Nun, nach der Auffassung Kiews, aber auch
der EU und USA ist die Antwort klar: aus RUSSLAND.
Ganz genau: Russland.
Kiew drängt darauf, das eingefrorene Vermögen
der Reserven der russischen Zentralbank, des
russischen Staates und seiner Oligarchen für
genau diesen Zweck zu verwerten.
Aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt wirft dies einige
sehr offensichtliche Probleme auf.
Einfrieren ist das eine, aber Enteignung etwas
ganz anderes.
Falls diese nicht nach rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien
verläuft, könnte sie die Rolle von Dollar
und Euro als Weltreservewährungen in Frage
stellen.
Wenn die USA und ihre Verbündeten den Reichtum
eines Staates so einfach enteignen können,
könnten Länder wie China oder Saudi-Arabien
und viele andere beschließen, dass es alles
andere als sicher ist, ihre Reserven in Dollar
zu halten.
Und was das Privatvermögen der Oligarchen
angeht: Das Problem ist, dass sich die Russen
seit Jahren auf eine solche Situation vorbereitet
haben und, anders als es vielleicht den Anschein
hat, nicht so viele Vermögenswerte beschlagnahmt
wurden.
Die Schweizer Behörden geben zum Beispiel
rund 8 Milliarden Dollar an.
Theoretisch ist das nicht schlecht, aber es
reicht nicht aus, wenn der Arbeitgeberverband
angibt, dass Schweizer Banken mehr als 200
Milliarden Dollar an russischem Vermögen
besitzen.
Allerdings ist die oftmals gescholtene Schweiz
trotz alldem immer noch der einsame Spitzenreiter:
Deutschland, welches ja als großes Paradies
für die Geldwäsche russischer Oligarchen,
italienischer Mafiosi und arabischer Clans
gilt, hat bisher lediglich 143 Millionen Euro
beschlagnahmen können.
In Spanien bitten die Notare die Regierung
um neue gesetzliche Maßnahmen, da sie der
Meinung sind, dass sie nach den derzeitigen
Gesetzen nicht gegen die russischen Oligarchen
vorgehen können.
Und Portugal...
Nun, alles, was wir über Portugal sagen können,
ist dies:
(Portugal friert nur ein russisches Konto
ein, auf dem 242 Euro lagen - Swissinfo)
Ein weiteres Problem ist, dass es sich um
Maßnahmen handelt, die das Privateigentum
verletzen.
Es ist klar, dass Russland als Staat für
den in der Ukraine angerichteten Schaden aufkommen
muss, aber inwieweit ist es gerecht, dass
Privatpersonen dafür zahlen?
Sollten Europa und die USA ihre eigenen rechtsstaatlichen
Prinzipien verletzen?
Das gibt zu denken, denn es wird ein Präzedenzfall
geschaffen, von dem man nie weiß, wo er enden
könnte.
Und wie in Versailles wäre es nicht das erste
Mal, dass sehr harte Friedensbedingungen einen
noch größeren Konflikt auslösen.
Es ist also klar, dass die Verwendung russischer
Mittel zum Wiederaufbau der Ukraine ganz klaren
und anerkannten internationalen Standards
für Reparationen entsprechen muss.
Und diese rechtlichen Grundlage werden gerade
jetzt konsequent und Schritt für Schritt
geschaffen.
Die Jagd auf russische Vermögen ist nun ganz
legal eröffnet.
In einer Veröffentlichung der EU-Kommission
heißt es, "dass das Vermögen von Personen
und Einrichtungen, die Straftatbestände gemäß
Artikel 83 des Vertrags über die Arbeitsweise
der Europäischen Union begehen in Zukunft
wirksam eingezogen werden kann".
In diese ersten Schritt geht es also darum,
dass Verstöße gegen die EU-Sanktionen gegen
Russland in die Liste der EU-Straftaten aufgenommen
werden.
Gemeint sind damit eine Reihe durch die EU
benannter Oligarchen, welche ihre Vermögen
durch Unterstützung von und Verwicklung in
die Kriegsmaschinerie Russlands eben auf kriminelle
Weise verdient haben.
Auf dem Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos kündigte
die Chefin der EU-Kommission Von der Leyen
die Gründung einer Wiederaufbau-Plattform
für die Ukraine an, damit diese sich wieder
aus der Asche erheben könne.
Dabei solle man nichts unversucht lassen,
einschließlich der möglichen Verwendung
russischer Vermögenswerte.
Die Idee soll nun in einem soeben vorgelegten
Gesetzesvorschlag der EU umgesetzt werden,
durch den die eingefrorenen Devisenreserven
der russischen Zentralbank angezapft und einer
neuen Bestimmung zugeführt werden könnten.
Von Russlands Devisenreserven von insgesamt
585 Mrd. USD wird allerdings nicht die volle
Summe für die Bezahlung von Schäden zur
Verfügung stehen.
Das liegt daran, dass Russland 22% dieser
Summe im eigenen Land als Gold hält, 14%
als Renminbi in China bunkert und weitere
5% in internationalen Institutionen hält,
auf welche die Alliierten bisher keinen Zugriff
haben.
Zieht man diese Beträge ab, verbleiben rund
350 Mrd. USD, die verteilt werden können.
In der Vergangenheit wurden die Reparationen
nach Beendigung der Feindseligkeiten von dem
Land gezahlt, das die Aggression ausgelöst
hatte - in den ersten beiden Weltkriegen war
dies Deutschland.
Es musste hierzu jedoch mit Waffengewalt gezwungen
oder gar besetzt werden.
Dies wird im Falle Russlands nicht nötig
sein, da viele gegen Russland verbündete
Länder ja bereits die Kontrolle über Russlands
Devisenbestände haben, 12% der Reserven liegen
zur Zeit in Frankreich, 10% in Deutschland,
weitere 10% in Japan und 7% in den USA, während
der Rest auf viele andere kooperierende Länder
verteilt ist.
Diese Tatsache bedeutet, dass die Reparationen
diesmal von Russland selbst quasi vorfinanziert
wurden.
Dies ist ein einzigartiger Umstand und jetzt
geht es nur noch darum, eine völkerrechtliche
Grundlage zu finden, damit diese Staaten die
eingefrorenen Mittel als Schadensersatz für
die Ukraine verwenden können.
Also: schauen wir uns diese doch mal an.
Gemäß US-Recht hat Russland in großem Umfang
und nachweisbar "vorsätzliche unerlaubte
Kriegshandlungen" begangen.
Dieser Tatbestand umfasst nicht provozierte
Gewalt gegen andere Staaten und ihre Bürger
und verlangt als Konsquenz, dass der Aggressor
als absolutes Minimum für das menschliche
Leid, Todesfälle und Sachverluste Schadenersatz
leistet.
Im Dezember 2005 verabschiedete die Generalversammlung
der Vereinten Nationen eine Resolution, die
eine Abwandlung der Doktrin der vorsätzlichen
unerlaubten Handlung bekräftigt, indem sie
den Opfern von Menschenrechtsverletzungen
nach internationalem Recht ein Recht auf Wiedergutmachung
zuspricht.
In diese UN-Resolution werden die Mitgliedsstaaten
gar aufgefordert, "nationale Programme zur
Wiedergutmachung und sonstigen Unterstützung
der Opfer für den Fall einzurichten, dass
die für den erlittenen Schaden verantwortlichen
Parteien nicht in der Lage oder nicht willens
sind, ihren Verpflichtungen nachzukommen".
Da es als ziemlich sicher gilt, dass Russland
– zumindest unter dem Regime Putin – nicht
bereit sein wird, diese Verpflichtungen zu
erfüllen, können andere Länder, die jetzt
russische Reserven halten, eine eigene völkerrechtlich
legitime Task Force für die Wiedergutmachung
der massiven durch Russland begangenen Menschenrechtsverletzungen
einrichten.
Als erstes muss diese Task Force ein Verfahren
zur Erstattung der Kosten für humanitäre
Hilfe, Asyl und Umsiedung entwickeln, die
von den europäischen Ländern getragen werden,
die ukrainische Flüchtlinge aufnehmen.
Diese könnten über 50 Milliarden betragen.
Zweitens sollten vom Krieg betroffene ukrainische
Bürger für den Verlust ihres Eigentums entschädigt
werden.
Wenn die Entschädigung für 11 Millionen
ukrainische Familien im Durchschnitt 20.000
Dollar pro Familie beträgt, würde sich die
Gesamtsumme auf 220 Milliarden Dollar belaufen.
Hinzu kämen potenziell Dutzende von Milliarden,
um Hinterbliebene für den gewaltsamen Tod
ihrer Angehörigen zu entschädigen, der durch
die russische Invasion verursacht wurde - sowohl
militärisch als auch auf andere Art und Weise,
z.B. durch die Unterbrechung des Zugang zu
Gesundheitseinrichtungen und Medikamenten.
Zu guter Letzt muss der Wiederaufbau finanziert
werden, sobald der Krieg beendet ist.
Bis dahin würden diese Mittel treuhänderisch
verwaltet.
Ein Betrag von mehr als 100 Milliarden US-Dollar
wäre hier realistisch, dieser steigt jedoch
mit jedem weiteren Kriegstag an.
Zum Umsetzung der Maßnahmen wird es noch
erforderlich sein, dass die Parlamente der
teilnehmenden Länder der Reparations-Task-Force
weitreichenden Befugnisse gewähren.
Auf Regierungsebene werden dann die Zentralbanken
angewiesen, die Mittel an eine Abwicklungsinstitution
zu überweisen, welche die technischen Voraussetzungen
ihrer Verteilung managt, z. B. an die Bank
für Internationalen Zahlungsausgleich.
Alter kann auch jedes Land anteilige Zahlungen
nach einem vereinbarten Zeitplan vornehmen.
Es ist möglich, wenn auch eher unwahrscheinlich,
dass die verfügbaren 350 Mrd. USD durch die
Finanzierung aller drei Komponenten dieses
Plans erschöpft wären - vor allem, wenn
die beteiligten Länder beschließen, einen
Teil der Reserven im Rahmen eines Friedensabkommens
an Russland zurückzugeben.
Dies könnte einen Anreiz für eine mögliche
neue Führung in Russland darstellen, zu kooperieren.
Allerdings scheinen im Augenblick die Aussichten,
dass Russland auch nur einen Cent seiner blockierten
Reserven wiedersieht äußerst minimal zu
sein, auch wenn Staaten wie das in der EU
zunehmend isolierte Deutschland ihre russischen
Oligarchen-Kumpels noch nicht ganz fallen
lassen wollen und vor allem ein kleines Land
besonders stark bockt: Ungarn.
Aber über den Spezialfall des Victor Orban
und seine Verstrickungen in die russische
Kriegs-Mafia werden wir schon bald ein ganz
eigenes Video drehen.
Vergesst also bitte nicht das Abo und bitte
auch nicht das Glöckchen, um es auf gar keinen
Fall zu verpassen.
Auf jeden Fall seid Ihr jetzt erst mal mit
Eurer Meinung an der Reihe: Denkt Ihr, dass
Europa die Ukraine unterstützen und ihren
Wiederaufbau finanzieren sollte?
Welche Chancen seht ihr z.B. für die europäische
Wirtschaft?
Sollten außerdem auch Russland und seine
Oligarchen dazu gezwungen werden sollten,
für alle Schäden ihrer Invasion zu zahlen?
Wie immer sind wir schon auf Eure Beiträge
im Kommentarbereich gespannt!
Ich hoffe, dass Euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und Ihr vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt
habt.
Falls ja, gebt uns bitte ein Like, teilt es
mit Euren Freunden und vergesst nicht das
Abo mit Glöckchen, um keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen.
Natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über
eine Spende von Euch, mit der Ihr uns helft,
dieses Projekt weiterzuführen.
Den PayPal-Link dazu findet Ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video.
Macht’s gut und bis bald!